pour regarder moi ce truc regardez-moi
ça la boîte elle est hyper bien réussi
c'est un nouveau smartphone de gaming
dont je vais vous parler aujourd'hui à 3
fin de ganic est sorti il ya très très
peu de temps donc il est effectivement
nouveau c'est un smartphone de nu bien
c'est le raid magic 5 g 5 g oui alors
vous arrêtez pas forcément encore tout
de suite la 5g chez vous mais ça ne
saurait tarder mais ce smartphone l'art
tout cas il est dans la boîte
normalement eh bien il peut avoir la 5e
j alors il fait plein plein plein plein
de jolies promesses et pas ses promesses
le fait d'avoir un écran avec un taux de
rafraîchissement de 144 hertz c'est à
dire de vous afficher en une seule
seconde
144 image différente alors je sais pas
si vous avez suivi mais il ya eu un gros
focus au niveau du grand public l'année
dernière c'était les smartphones en 90
hertz c'est à dire 80 10 images par
seconde
basiquement il faut savoir que vous avez
60 images par seconde sur un smartphone
cette année on a basculé sur des
smartphones très haut de gamme en 120
images par seconde et la lui via vient
nous chercher un coach mark von en 144
images par seconde alors est-ce que ce
144 images par seconde dans ce
smartphone qui est là j'ai déjà sorti
vous vous en douterez est ce que ça
apporte vraiment quelque chose
qu'est-ce qu'il ya un réel intérêt du
fait d'avoir 144 images par seconde
est-ce que ce nubia ce raid magic 5 g
est intéressant gardez ça la jolie
couleur vous avez derrière
est-ce qu'il est fait pour vous quels
sont ses points forts quelles sont ses
faiblesses il ya plein de choses à dire
dessus
mais avant toute chose je vous invite à
vous abonner si ce n'est pas déjà le cas
puisque je vous présente beaucoup de
smartphones des montants collectés les
tablettes ordinateurs donne des astuces
et des plus tôt pour mieux utiliser ces
petites bêtes là pour avoir une vie tech
beaucoup plus simple beaucoup plus
pratique beaucoup plus optimisée donc si
ce n'est pas déjà le cas vous invite à
vous abonner dès maintenant je vais
d'abord commencer par vous faire faire
un tour de la boîte parce que je pense
que du bien vraiment bien bossé vous
avez quelque chose qui est extrêmement
jolie bien réussi on voit bien raide
magic ici une boîte qui est vraiment
cool est vraiment dans l'esprit gaming
alors lorsque vous venez l'ouvrir vous
avez votre smartphone qui est situé
juste là les choses sont très claires
c'est écrit noir sur blanc raid magic on
vient tirer si on va se retrouver avec
le bloc de charge le câble
d'alimentation un peu doc
donc à part grand grand grande surprise
intérieur mais ce que j'aime bien ce que
je trouve très sympa en tout cas c'est
l'idée de cette boîte qui est très cali
qui vient vraiment s'affirmer une fois
de plus dans l'esprit gagner le
smartphone aux lumas mais aussi très
très très sympa si vous le regardez sur
la face avant on peut pas se rendre
compte
ce smartphone de gimme il ne transpire
pas le smartphone de gaming de ce côté
là pour vraiment se rendre compte qu'il
faut prendre et venir le basculer et là
les choses sont tout de suite beaucoup
plus clair horreur de bayonne nubia
rennes magic vous avez le petit 5 g vous
voyez tout ce côté étoilé la même au
niveau des caméras ses terres et au sec
le liseré rouge tout au tour ici c'est
vraiment un smartphone qui est très
sympa et alors il a une particularité
et ça c'est vraiment un point qui est
extrêmement fort si vous êtes gamer et
si vous la petite façon il faut
l'acheter parce qu'on a des moeurs n'y a
pas beaucoup d'intérêt
vous avez ici des petites rigueur pour
venir jouer ça vous sert un peu de
commande tactile vous en avez un ici
vous avez l'hôte de la côté ici le
bouton pour via l'allumé pour l'éteindre
et si vous montez et vous baissez le son
c'est un grand classique
ici c'est une sortie d'air et de l'autre
côté vous avez la prise d'air puisque
votre ventilateur se trouve ici l'air
est aspiré ici ça vient refroidir le
ventilateur tourne et ça vous sort l'air
chaud ce côté là sur le dessous vous
avez de quoi bien branché un accessoire
que je n'ai pas donc je pas pouvoir trop
vous vouliez vous en parler aujourd'hui
et si vous êtes un bouton qui est
vachement intéressant qui vous permet de
switcher pour entrer directement dans le
mode gay ni sur le dessus on va
retrouver une petite prise jack
donc ça c'est aussi très très bien pour
pouvoir si vous le souhaitez brancher un
casque pour des parties 10 millions
diable et le micro pour la réduction
bouée puis sur le dessous qu'on va
trouver le micro le tireur de cartes sim
avec de la double sim un haut parleur
qui situe la de la recharge en usb si
bien évidemment vous avez le deuxième
haut parleur que si tu es ici en façade
et qui marche extrêmement bien et ça je
vous le détailler aussi dans quelques
instants
bon je vous cache pas que c'est pas le
smartphone le plus léger mais bon ça
voir un bout de bois on s'en sort quand
même pas trop mal
il a un don ou vert ça s'est vraiment
bien très qualitatif il prend quelques
petites traces de doigts mais c'est pas
extrêmement dérangeant un petit coup de
chiffonnette ses propres ce qu'on peut
peut-être reprocher c'est les bordures
voyez vous comme une bordure qui est
assez grande en eau
également assez grande en bas on n'est
pas dans quelque chose de très très très
discret mais une fois que vous venez
activer le dark monde ici eh bien voyez
tout disparaît ça se fond dans la masse
donc bon pourquoi pas on a senti un
capteur d'empreintes digitales qui est
extrêmement rapide et réactif pour venir
le déverrouiller ça s'annonce bien là
tout un châssis qui est en métal
la prise en main est bonne et voyez moi
j'ai pas d énormes mains et voilà je
fais pas le tour mais doivent se touche
mais avec beaucoup de difficultés
l'écran parlons-en parce que c'est le
point le plus intéressant c'est vraiment
ce qui va venir en tout cas attiré leur
attention là dessus ici vous avez un
écran de 6,65 pouces et un écran amoled
full hd + 2340 par 1080 à 387,5 pixels
par pouce faut être extrêmement précis
et surtout ce qui est intéressant c'est
le tout
rafraîchissements alors moi je l'aimé en
144 m si vous regardez bien ça vous la
fiche même ici au mais vous pouvez
choisir ce que vous voulez soit de 60
hertz là vous allez vraiment venir
gagner en autonomie lorsque vous n'avez
plus beaucoup de batterie sinon vous
switchez en 90 ou alors on 144 hertz
pour le forcer il faut vraiment savoir
est d'ailleurs il voulut marque ici que
lorsque vous êtes en 90 hertz ou en 144
hertz et bien c'est le smartphone
qu'elle n'en choisir de façon
intelligente ce dont vous avez
réellement besoin pour vous éviter de
surconsommer la batterie du smartphone
d'un point de vue purement logiciel vous
avez tout ce qui va bien vous voulez
régler bien évidemment la luminosité ou
luminosité automatique et me régler les
préférences
ici il est en 100% des ces ip trois
palis régler la chaleur plus froid plus
chaud maintenant ce sera tout de suite
venir regretter et on le voit
directement et sans gros reproche que je
vais adresser à lui bien c'est tout
simplement que leur surcouche rennes
magic os 3.0 et bien elle est
extrêmement mal traduites voir pas
traduite par endroits là vous voyez
affichage niveau luminosité screen
display préférence screen refresh wright
et ça vous retrouver partout et c'est
pas terrible
aussi bien au niveau des paramètres que
dans la partie photo on a du mal à s'y
retrouver si vous parlais pas la langue
de shakespeare et bien ça va tout de
suite être la galère pour un smartphone
qui vous amène à un peu plus de 500
euros
j'aurais trouvé ça de bon ton que
nubienne traduire parfaitement sa
surcouche
j'imagine que ça va être le cas dans une
mise à jour mais pour l'instant en tout
cas alors à la cage où il présentait
bien ce n'est toujours pas le cas
au-delà de ça vous avez un ralph d'écran
de 19 points 5/9 qui fait bien le taf
vous avez une luminosité maximale de six
ans dit je me suis mis dehors
il ya un soleil de plomb on voit c'est
mieux de se mettre un peu à londres
c'est pas idéal mais ça marche un écran
qui est aussi certifié lutter contre la
lumière bleue mais ce n'est pas tout
puisque lorsqu'on parle d'écran 144 est
ce qu'on parle de gaming on parle
d'expérience multimédia accès dédié
complètement sûr gaming alors qu'est ce
que serait multimédia sans une bonne
expérience audio je vous le demande
et bah ça serait un petit peu pas
terrible et là aussi nubia vraiment bien
bossé on nous proposons des haut
parleurs stéréo qui sont puissants qui
respecte qui est l'art dans la mesure de
ce qu'est capable de vous proposer un
smartphone
où je croirais presque de retour au même
poste il ya un souk aient vraiment très
très fort il ya quand même beaucoup de
puissance sacrée cool et pour des
expériences de game pour du multimédia
c'est vraiment dire mais c'est ça ne
vous suffit pas et comme je vous le
disais bien vous êtes toujours la
possibilité de mettre aux prises diack
si vous ne voulez pas déranger des gens
dans les transports en commun si vous
voulez pas déranger vos parents qui
dorment vos voisins votre soeur votre
colloque qui vous voulez et bien pour
mettre un casque avec une prise jack et
là aussi le son est vraiment de bonne
qualité ça marche très bien et si vous
voulez un casque et vous avez un casque
sans fil et bien vous avez du bluetooth
cinq points qui va bien donc d'un point
de vue expérientiel purement audio et
bien ça marche vraiment très très bien
mais là on se parle de gaming vous êtes
d'accord avec moi donc à un smartphone
gainey c'est bien qu'il ait mon écran
c'est bien que les deux soient de
qualité mais il faut quand même derrière
beaucoup de performances
et puis c'est bien de rajouter quelque
chose à l'expérience l'a justement vous
avez des vibrations pouvait venir
activer désactiver dans votre mode de
gaming j'aime bien vous montrer ça et ça
marche vraiment bien pas toujours tous
les jeux mais si vous prenez par exemple
un objet vous prenez un espagnol ça
marche et c'est vraiment hyper
qualitatif mais ce qui est plus
important sur un smartphone de gaming
surtout ici vous le martyre 5g et bien
il vous faut un smartphone extrêmement
performant et si lui bien n'a absolument
pas lésiné jeu qui vous ont dit ce qui
se fait de mieux à l'heure actuelle cela
dragon 865 bien évidemment 5g et danser
jusqu à 2,84 gigahertz
vous avez soit 8 soit 12 ya drame lp
ddr5 ce qui serait lui aussi à l'heure
actuelle et vous avez soit 128 soit 256
go de stockage non extensible en ef s
3.0 et regardez surtout on attend même
le score de 550 1983 ce qui vient vous
le classée à la 4e position en dessous
du chien aux milices pro que si une
petite tuerie en dessous du one + 8 pro
qui est aussi une petite tuerie en
dessous du midi ce fut aussi une petite
tuerie c'est la même chose en terme de
performances il est au dessus du samsung
galaxy s 20 ultra avec l'exynos 1990 bon
après ils ont appliqué une formule qui
m'a ils ont mis se tiennent mieux
aujourd'hui en termes de composants donc
c'est évident que le smartphone
d'arrière et bien ils carburent mais il
ya tout qui est aussi intéressant il
faut savoir que la 5g ça a plutôt
tendance à chauffer voir a beaucoup
chauffé et bien ici vous avez un petit
ventilateur pour pouvoir retrouver un
jour lady ici au milieu le point positif
est que ça fait rentrer de l'air et ça
fait sortir
donc ça dissipe vraiment la chaleur de
votre smartphone notamment par rapport à
l' usage 5 g mais surtout
par rapport à usage des ming donc ça
c'est bien maintenant le point négatif
c'est que comme c'est ouvert il s'y
voyait que vous avez forcément c'est
triste d'air qui situent juste ici et
bien vous n'avez pas de certification ip
autant vous dire que ce smartphone est
absolument pas étanche
évitez donc de le mettre dans l'eau
autant certains smartphones dont
fortifications ip et ne craignent pas de
rencontre avant un petit peu d'eau celui
là je ne m'y amuse ray pas puisque le
ventilateur est fait pour faire rentrer
l'air et faire sortir ce sera exactement
la même chose avec de l'eau alors sera
pas le 24 heures qu'il le fera mais d'un
point de vue purement mécanique ça
rentrera et sa noire à votre smartphone
on peut pas tout avoir un aussi faire
des choix d'assumer que sur un
smartphone de gaming sans mode dimming
et bien le mode gaming vous l'avez en
activant ça regardez le sens que ça sort
c'est absolument incroyable voix vous
allez retrouver vos jeux voyez ici j'ai
mis les essentiels pour moi à sfax 9 est
complètement optimisé fortnight je n'ai
absolument pas réussi à le faire tourner
à le charger à rien du tout donc je ne
saurais pas vous dire pourquoi mais
fortnight ne marche pas là dessus en
tout cas lors de mon test badji marche
aussi merveilleusement bien et après
vous avez plein de petits réglages ici
j'ai mon volonté de réactiver je suis
sur mon écran 144 hertz venir faire pas
mal de choses bloquer les sms bloquer
les appels bloquer des touches faire des
captures d'écran enregistrer mon écran
et là j'ai bien paramétré mais trigger
celui-là correspond aux boutons la
celui-là correspond aux boutons là et
ensuite j'ai vraiment le paramétrer
comme je le souhaite gk venir ici dans
mon propre rigueur et voyez ils sont
assignés ici ici je peux vraiment les
paramétrer fonction de chaque
application comme ça il va vraiment me
garder en mémoire et après ça marche
vraiment bien alors que vendre était pas
content comme ça mais le taux de
rafraîchissement est vraiment énorme
c'est complètement génial ça marche
super man bien et c'est vraiment cool de
pouvoir jouer comme ça que les boutons
sur un sac là c'est la même chose
d'assez du mode turbo
si je signe mais dérapages ici voyez opf
et de couches dérape c'est les petits
loopings et on se dit qu appuyé sur le
bouton pour choisir ma direction vous
voyez si c'est exactement la même chose
avec tous vos paramètres vous pouvez
venir régler les clercs forme ans de
votre cpu mois chez nous poussés à fond
vous pouvez mettre en mode automatique
vous pouvez pousser la carte graphique
poussé le processeur vous mettre tout au
maximum par contre si l'autonomie va
réduire comme peau de chagrin
vous avez vos propres eager pour venir
mettre des contrôleurs mais moi aussi
j'en ai absolument pas venir choisir
votre fréquence de rafraîchissement de
votre image votre ventilateur vous
connecter sur moi de sa part même temps
souhaité venir partager avec vous
amy bon moi je n'ai pas relié mais
pourrait le faire si vous le voulez donc
ça c'est un gros il parle de petites
options le cas des chocs pour avoir les
vibrations faire des captures d'écran
voyez quand même pas mal de petites
possibilités donc ça c'est vraiment bien
pour tourner dans votre gamespace ici
vous avez soit votre liste
d'applications soit vous l'avez comme ça
directement c'est beaucoup plus sympa
ici vous voyez calais petit contrôleur
mais moi je les ai pas donc
malheureusement je peux pas dire vous
les présenter mais ça permet d'amener
l'expérience encore plus loin donc
pourquoi pas et puis après les réglages
que vous allez avoir ici et notamment au
niveau du ventilateur avec un contrôle
intelligent ou alors avec leur rapide
cooling et là il s'est quand même un peu
plus de bruit rade et je vous fait
écouter vous avez bien évidemment les
effets de l'aide pour venir choisir la
couleur
là je suis en rouge peut bien passer en
multicolore voyez ça me fait une espèce
de côté un peu multicolores
j'ai toutes les possibilités de venir
choisir les effets respiration le côté
un peu flash vraiment le customiser me
faire une équipe et il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de possibilités donc si vous
êtes vraiment fan de ea sports que vous
êtes un passionné des ennemis bien voyez
vous êtes quand même de quoi faire
donc tout ça c'est bien mais aussi un
poc extrêmement important c'est
l'autonomie puisque comme je le disais
un écran de 144 hertz ça vient quand
même consommer davantage
ici vous avez une grosse batterie de
4500 millions terreur vous avez des
recharges 18 watts qui inclut c'est pas
la recharge la plus rapide mais vous
pouvez monter jusqu'à une charge 50 100
watts qui vont venir acheter séparément
ici vous en douterez il n'y a pas de
charge sans fil pas de charge l'inversé
mais est ce que c'est vraiment ce que
vous allez venir chercher sur ce
smartphone là je ne suis pas convaincu
la question l'autonomie la teneur est
aussi un petit peu plus complexe parce
que bien évidemment ça va dépendre de
vous de vos usages ça va dépendre du
taux de rafraîchissement ce smartphone
là il est fait pour être utilisée pour
être secoué pour venir s'amuser et
pousser au maximum d'expérience donc dès
que si vous jouez beaucoup en soit 44 rc
vous poussez les performances à fond et
bien votre smartphone si vous regardez
une journée vous êtes quand même
relativement content si par contre on
fait attention que vous le plus c'est
par maximum que vous jouer de temps en
temps vous consultez des réseaux sociaux
et vous n'êtes pas trop gourmand et bien
vous pouvez pousser jusqu'à un jour et
demi voire deux jours mais au-delà de ça
ça va être un peu compliqué il ya
néanmoins banque est très important
qu'il faut vraiment savoir c'est que ce
smartphone là vous n'avez pas pouvoir
faire tourner netflix ni my canal en hd
vous serez uniquement sd donc dans une
qualité qui est aujourd'hui très
acceptable c'est à dire vous allez faire
tourner en 576p autant vous dire la
qualité est vraiment pas terrible
donc si pour vous l'expérience de
visionnage de séries films sur notamment
netflix cm canal est importante et bien
voilà ça c'est un de ses points faibles
je ne suis pas sûr que ça fait pour vous
dans ce cas là comme ça au smartphone
vous en douterez il sait faire des
photos mais c'est pas nécessairement ce
qu'on va venir chercher là dessus ici
vous avez un triple module photo vous
allez retrouver une caméra principale de
64 mégapixels c'est la somme i mx 686
qui ouvre à f 1.8 vous avez aussi un
ultra grand angle de 8 mégapixels avec
un champ de vision de 120° qui ouvre à f
2.2 et puis vous avez de la macro et oui
de la macro en 2 mégapixels tous vos
rêves 2.4 c'est assez bizarre dormi la
macro la fois bien filmé jusqu'à huit
cas bon voilà pourquoi pas mais vous
allez voir c'est pas extraordinaire
et vous avez à l'avant une caméra de
saïfi qui est bloqué juste ici la caméra
de 8 mégapixels kovalev 2.0 moyens une
fois puis surtout qui me dérange un peu
c'est toujours sur l'expérience purement
logicielle je voulais dire les problèmes
de traduction et surtout on comprend pas
grand chose par exemple je suis ici je
sais que c'est une caméra ultra
grand-angle dites moi où la trouver si
vous le voyez tout de suite dit le mois
voulait marquer en bas en commentaire
parce que moi je vois pas
particulièrement je trouve pas ça très
très très intuitive voyez là pour unir
ou mais ici vous monté jusqu'à 1 x 10
qui est pas du tout stabiliser même sur
le foin on n'est pas stabilisée on est
sûr attentes de gaming très riche et
donc la photo c'est pas trop trop son
truc
vous allez pouvoir retrouver ici plein
de choses mais pour comprendre
réellement de quoi il s'agit et bien je
vous souhaite bon courage alors on
devine bien la macro on la comprend mais
il ya plein de choses je vois ça je ne
sais pas de quoi on parle
je sais pas vraiment je ne comprends pas
donc je pense qu'en termes d'expérience
purement utilisateurs il ya vraiment
quand même pas mal de choses à revoir de
ce côté là on voit que le smartphone
n'est pas prévu pour être vus pas trop
je pense les francophones vous pouvez
lire film est bien évidemment là je vous
ai mis au 8 calmer en lui qu'avec vous
absolument aucune stabilisation si vous
voulez de la stabilisation vous
descendez en 4k là vous aurez quelque
chose qui fonctionne
soit vous dites que vous venez de tenir
à la main soit vous le posez sur un
trépied et là on n'est plus du tout
stabiliser ses réalisations électronique
vous en douterez ça vient cros payant
l'image je vous montre le résultat vous
allez voir c'est pas complètement dingue
ça c'est une photo plus avec le capteur
principal ça marche bien ce sont 4
mégapixels et maîtrisée et des combien
se rapprocher zoom et se rapproche il
récupère beaucoup de bruit c'est très
imprécis on continue jusqu'au x 10 et
voyez c'est pas extraordinaire là on
arrive sur les bouteilles de la macro or
la macro
moi je suis pas fan déjà d'une macro
avec les capteur de 2 mégapixels je
trouve que le rendu n'est pas hyper
qualitatif on arrive bien avoir quelques
petites choses mais il ya beaucoup de
bruit tous les côtés sa performance un
peu alice et et le rendent une fois de
plus pour moi là dessus voilà c'est par
vous fiez entité fait rigolo mais c'est
pas utilisable le mode portrait
fonctionne dans l'absolu plutôt bien
plus derrière on a beaucoup de puissance
pour me refaire les calculs
néanmoins on voit qu'ici il a eu un peu
plus de mal
et pareil au niveau des cheveux ici il
n'ya pas parfaitement détour et en
beauté du siècle une photo celle fils a
fait le boulot mais une fois de plus
c'est pas extraordinaire
ici le capteur principal qui est quand
même très très très bon a malgré tout je
tiens à préciser que c'est vraiment le
point positif donc s'ils voulaient faire
des photos avec le capteur principal
sans venir zoomer et bien vous aurez un
rendu de qualité
rien n'est crâne et le détail est quand
même plutôt bons pour voir qu'on un
contre jour derrière ça marche
bon pour un peu négatif c'est quand même
un petit peu trop saturé mais voyez on a
bien tous les détails au niveau de la
peau on a les petits rayons du soleil
qui arrivent dessus on voit bien
également les feuilles devant au premier
plan on voit même juste les détails ici
don veuillez bon pour chanter quelques
photos de qualité ça ira très bien qu'on
continue maintenant les photos prises
dans des conditions de nuit il n'y a
aucun éclairage dans la pièce mise à
part les volets fermés qui laisse passer
un tout petit peu de lumière et bien
dans l'absolu c'est pas mauvais c'est
pas dingue c'est un peu brute est le
même ici ça fonctionne sensiblement et
puis là où seul avait carrément beaucoup
moins lumière bon voilà c'est pas idéal
mais on peut faire quelques petites
choses avec ce smartphone est donc
excellent pour tout ce qui va être
gaming pour tout le reste il est un peu
moins bon malgré tout il ya du wifi si
je vous ai dit la 5g stand alone
l'espagnol bon on va pas rentrer côté un
peu technique mais en gros si vous
l'avez aujourd'hui vous êtes prêts pour
la 5g
il a dû annuler ces il existe dans deux
configurations 8 +128 gia de stockage à
579 euros et 12 plus 256 go de stockage
à 649 euros d'ailleurs s'il vous
intéresse vous avez des liens en bas
d'un description pouvait aller jeter un
petit coup d'oeil
le retour est toujours un peu délicat
parce que ce smartphone je le trouve
vraiment très très bien je trouve très
performant je trouve excellent pour
l'expérience gaming pour moi c'est un
très bon smartphone de gaming pour du
multimédia sur youtube
il est aussi très bon pour tout ce qui
va être netflix mike annales comme nous
le disait là on est complètement en
dessous et c'est pas un smartphone qui
va être fait pour ces usages là et c'est
vraiment très dommage parce que ce sont
aujourd'hui des
extrêmement important au point qui est
aussi un peu négatif mais sur votre
smartphone de gaming c'est pas anormal
c'est la partie photo qui quand même pas
extraordinaire mais pour tout le reste
il est quand même plutôt bien donc il
faut vraiment savoir où vous allez
ce que vous faites quels sont vos usages
qu'est ce que vous faites aujourd'hui et
qu'est ce que vous ferez demain et est
ce que ce smartphone peut vraiment
répondre à vos besoins et à vos usages
ailleurs dites le moi vous en bas en
commentaire quels sont vos usages et
est-ce que vous pensez que le rêve magic
5g peut vraiment dire coché toutes les
cases ou alors est-ce que vous pensez
que le fait que netflix et notamment by
canal ne soit pas en hd soit en sd est
ce que ça vous pose problème ou pas
est-ce que vous l'utilisez ou pas est-ce
que vous utiliser ses services
ou pas et est-ce que vous jouez et si
vous jouez est ce que vous seriez prêt à
acheter ce smartphone
marc doussain 20 ans commentaire quant à
elle on se retrouve demain on continue à
parler tu accuses emballement des gros
becs beaucoup d'amour et ya très très
vite ciao
du
[Musique]